I think yeah and I'm very glad we have a
fika are talking about another very
controversial topic
so thank you so this controversial topic
was suggested to me by the organizers
and I needed to fill it up with some
content so there are many things I can
speak about and eventually I chose some
subtopic with that within it so the plan
of the talk is as follows will consider
nearly five problems so max police at
mean by section three coloring unique
games and dances okay sub graph and on
each of them try to look a little at the
interplay between a algorithms for worst
case instances and for random instances
and to see if one informs the other so
like a question to keep in mind during
the talk is the following that that the
study of algorithms that handle random
inputs help in designing approximation
algorithms for states in senses and in
general the picture can go either way
so sometimes they're related sometimes
they're not related it says something
that often happens when we design
algorithms for worst case instances is
they're really prepared themselves for
the walls and when a very easy instance
comes there is co-op completely and like
give the the worst possible
approximation ratio and very easy
instances but I'll try to say that
studying random instances helps in the
design of a worst case algorithms for
worst case instances so let's start with
max 3sat so here we have a Louisiana
formula with n variables and M clauses
and the goal is to find an assignment
that maximizes the number of clauses
that are satisfied so this is a
well-known problem it's well known that
a random assignment satisfies 7/8 of the
clauses in expectation so it's close by
itself as probability 1 a 7/8 of being
satisfied and valine ality of
expectation that's what you get and the
piece already gives an approximate
of 7/8 because at most you can satisfy
all the clauses and hostel proved that
achieving an approximation ratio better
than 7/8 is np-hard so this is what's
known about worst case instances so if
we look at random acts at let's go over
it slowly to understand what we mean by
the approximation algorithm for random
instances so here we have to specify a
distribution over random instances and
the distribution is you just pick the
formula completely at random
each lit arriving every close is chosen
independently at random like what the
variable is and what its polarity is and
now what do we mean when we say we have
an approximation algorithm for width
ratio for random instances the reason
this issue of random it doesn't always
have to work so what do we mean by this
so if the algorithm chooses to output an
assignment the assignment better be of
the following form that the number of
clauses are satisfied by the assignment
is guaranteed to be at least let's say
this Rho fraction times the number of
clauses that can be satisfied by the
optimal assignment so if it outputs an
assignment form it doesn't guarantee
both of how many clauses the assignment
satisfied and what's the maximum
possible number of clauses that can be
satisfied and the ratio between these
two numbers is all
that it's allowed also not to output and
assignment it can just say don't know
and this but you cannot always say don't
know so with probability it must have
over the distribution of a random
instances chosen from the distribution
so that's the notion of an approximation
that we shall consider for random
instances in here so no algorithm is
known or even conjecture to achieve an
approximation I should better than seven
eight on random instances let's say when
the number of clauses is some very large
constant times the number of valuables
lost figures and multicolor is not very
important so in a sense it's more like
Las Vegas or something I don't know if
that's Vegas so it's not it's not like P
P P in the side and since that there's
an arrow it does never run error in what
you will return you always answer
correctly you just within the
approximation ratio that you need to
achieve but you're allowed not to answer
so like there's no notion of arrows here
it's just the probability of not
answering
okay so we see that at least Felisa at
random instances appear to be as
difficult as well stress instances
because we for worst case we cannot do
better than seven eight and for random
we cannot do better than seven eight so
we can ask ourselves can we prove NP
hardness for random instances can we
prove that we cannot do better than
seven eight and random instances
unfortunately I'm not aware of any
technique of proving NP hardness results
for random instances as far as I know
there are no such results we can try to
ask whether the pattern that we see here
is more general so suppose that a
problem is NP how to approximate within
a ratio better than law in the worst
case then we can ask ourselves is there
some natural distribution so by natural
I mean something that lets say you can
sample form over inputs for which is how
to achieve an approximation ratio then
better than below and here I don't mean
a when I say how they don't mean any how
because we don't know how to prove and P
hardness for random instances but at
least that all our algorithms fail so is
this for 3sat this is what happens does
this happen for other problems as well
so any questions about max please up yes
and natural random problem where we know
is as far as I know no there are other
notions of hardness sometimes that you
can invent around random instances let's
say conjecture that some problem is hard
and then this other problem is also hard
but then not they haven't been tied
let's say to harness up three start
lifting
okay so now let's look at a different
problem I mean by section so the input
is an N vertex graph and we want to
partition its vertex set into two equal
sized parts minimizing the an and the
number of edges in the cut so here this
would be a by section with roughly
vertices on each side and there are two
edges in the cut
so what do we know about a mean by
section in the worst case so if we look
at the approximation algorithm so here
what you're allowed to do you still need
to output a cut which is completely
balanced and over two vertices on each
side and you asked by how much you your
bisection is larger than the minimum
bisection so there's an approximation
algorithm with an approximation ratio of
order of log n as say a little bit more
about this algorithm later and the only
how nice results known is that assuming
that NP does not have sub exponential
time algorithm still is some constant
maybe close to one such that you cannot
do have an approximation better than
that constant so there's a large gap in
what we know here people also considered
by criteria approximation so these
algorithms are allowed instead to of
outputting a completely balanced cut
they're allowed to output an almost
balanced cut let's say 49 percent of the
filter sits on one side 51 on the other
side and for such algorithms they're
proximation in the number of edges in
the cut improves to all the law of
square root of log N and also here there
are some hardness of approximation
assuming that NP does not have sub
exponential time algorithms
so now let's look at random instances of
bisection so here let's start with the
simplest random instance like we did
with Freesat and just take a random
graph with M edges and suppose that M is
much larger than aim just completely at
random so in this case the minimum
bisection it's not how to see if I
should've found an Union bound that the
minimum bisection is slightly very close
to em over to there's no good way
section in such random graphs any base
section would cut roughly half the edges
also the maximum bisection would be
roughly the same value slightly above M
over 2 and indeed we have algorithms
that certify this in polynomial time
that is proof for your particular
instance that there's no good way
section these are spectral algorithms so
let me explain a little so random graphs
if the number of edges is large enough
there are nearly regular so let's say
that the average degree is d so they are
nearly Dirigo almost every belt access
degree close between let's say d plus
minus square root of d so if we look at
the adjacency matrix of such a graph
it's not how to see that the largest
eigen value of the adjacency matrix is
roughly D because random graphs are very
good expanders the second largest
eigenvalue of the jason C matrix is
order of Square D with high probability
and you can in fact certify it you can
compute these eigen values and see that
this is indeed the case but on the other
on the other hand if there would have
been a small base section in the graph
though it's again not too hard to see I
will not prove it that in that case
there should have been not just to one
large again value of value linear in D
but at least two so the fact that you
don't find the second one is evidence
that the graph does not have a small
bisection
so on random instances if they're dense
enough the approximation ratio for a
mean by section is close to 1 so if we
recall what happened in the worst case
instances we had with we did not have
good hardness results and also for
random instances they don't seem to be
hard / - did you mean my M over 3 or yes
om I will tell you that saying I a and
let's I'll also get to this you know I
wanted to be
okay other distributions of random
graphs so you might not like the fact
that that in these run this module of
random graphs there really is no small
base section so you can ask what happens
on random graphs which do have small
base sections so how would you choose
such a graph so one way of trying to do
it is sample uniformly at random from
all graphs that to have small bisection
that would be one more than a so it
turns out that this model is pretty
close if the best if the number of edges
is large in the bisection is fairly
small to a model of a planted by section
so statistically close industry and the
model of a planted by section is you
first decide on your base section then
sample edges between the two parts with
some small probability and within each
of the two parts with high probability
so this would make this base section the
smallest a section and it turns out that
for all sufficiently dense graph with
meaning by section if it's significantly
smaller than M over 2 and here you don't
need something like M over 3 some M over
2 plus minus some low order terms would
in fact be enough you can find a minimum
by section in polynomial time
and moreover provide the proof that this
is indeed the minimum by section so you
actually find the exact minimum not in
approximation this was done a lot
already in 87 by bopanna it uses semi
definite programming so one way I think
of semi definite programming is that it
like a technique that combines two
aspects one the spectral techniques that
we've already seen in another Sam linear
component component and it's open
whether there's some or I I don't know
at least if there are some distribution
of L graphs for which it seems plausible
that achieving a constant factor
approximation is held so this I don't
know for minimum bisection
so let's look a bit about the algorithms
involved so for worst case instances the
current best by criteria approximation
algorithm use semi definite programming
which is also good for random instances
and in fact it adds constraints the
triangle inequalities that are not used
for the random instances this if we look
at to approximation algorithms that are
not by criteria they have to output an
exact weight section if the previous
best algorithm use the by criteria
approximation algorithm as a black box
and lost an additional log n factor but
the current best approximation algorithm
by raka so it does not use semi definite
programming at all
it's based on a different concept it's a
randomized embeddings of graphs into
trees where every edge suffers an
average load of all the log n so let me
spend just one slide explaining what
this concept is so think let's say this
is your whole graph both the black edges
and the blue edges and think of for
simplicity you pick a spanning tree in
this graph so the load of an edge in the
spanning tree would be the number of
edges that need to use it as the path is
out of a path between the end points now
that the edge was removed so let's say
if I look at this particular edge so
it's load is one for itself but also
because now I just have the spanning
tree this edge no longer exists so
instead it has to be routed through this
path the unique path between its end
point so it also contributes to the load
of this edge so the load of these edges
to the load of this edge is three
because they also give edge needs to be
routed through it so that's the load of
an edge
so if we look at this particular tree
and look now at a cut in the tree so the
cut contains two spanning tree edges so
two of the black edges it contains three
graph edges so also this edge and they
who really accounts for this edge it's
this edge because the load of this edge
would be two because of the existence of
this edge and it also contains another
if we look at the load of the cut it
really is 4 because the load of these
edges - so even though this cut that's 3
edges in the graph
it's load when a is really 4 so what
raqqa did was the following he said show
that every graph can be embedded for
simplicity let me say distribution of a
spanning tree so I'm cheating a little
bit here so every graph can be
distributed embedded into a distribution
of a spanning trees such that for every
edge in a graph if I look at its average
or load overall spanning trees it's at
most log n and ok so that's what he
showed and what yes for some so in some
clay so your what load might be in it
let's say for us for this edge let's say
now the load is zero it's not part of
the spanning tree so but over the whole
distribution your expected load is not
more than order of log N and then the
point is that once you have trees on
trees all kind of cut problems like
bisection become easy you can solve them
exactly in polynomial time using dynamic
programming so now on each of these
trees you can serve the minimum
bisection using dynamic programming and
you take the smallest one that you find
and it's not how to see that this is an
order log n approximation to the
original problem
so this is a different kind of algorithm
for cut problems and maybe a question to
ask here we have all these if we look at
random instances we somehow do not seem
to use this kind of algorithms for
random in these instances so do they
help in another question often when we
prove that certain algorithmic
techniques do not walk like the SOS hire
he does not do something I'm not sure
that these types of algorithms are
captured by SOS IO is so if people have
interested in proving that certain
algorithms do not work so here's the
class of algorithms for which I don't
think there was much work in trying to
show where they fail and part of the
problem is that you have a distribution
over trees it's enough that one tree
would be very good and you're done even
if all the rest of the trees in the
distributional bed
this is what they had to say about mean
bisection any questions on this
so now let's move to a different problem
three color ink so this is a free
coloring of this graph so you color the
vertices by three colors such that no
edge is a monochromatic every edge sees
at least two colors exactly two colors
so what do we know about the problem of
mint free coloring so the problem is the
following you're given a 3 colorable
graph and you want to legally color it
with as few colors as possible so every
Edge has to be legally color then you
want to use as few colors as possible so
this problem is np-hard and in fact it's
empty hard even if you have a three
color little graph to color it with four
colors is also np-hard it's open whether
it can be colored with five colors where
there's a polynomial time algorithm that
does it with five colors there's some
evidence that it's hard that's if you
believe in unique games or things like
that but no NP hardness oza so here I'd
be interested in graphs of maximum
degree D or really average degree D it
would be the same Andy you should think
of it as it can also be a function of n
so they can be some into the Delta here
so for this graph 3d coloring if we look
at maximum degree D 3d coloring uses at
most D plus 1 colors whenever you
achieve erotics
whatever colors its neighbors are using
you still have one color available for
the vertex and they break the result of
Qayamat one in sudan used semi definite
programming to show that in fact you can
if the graph is 3 colorable and degree
maximum degree D in fact you can color
it with roughly D to the one third
colors the cube root of D colors so this
uses a notion of vector three coloring
that are briefly explained
so the picture to have in mind is this
picture that if a graph is 3 colorable
you may think of trying to embed it in
the plane in the following way you
partition it into color classes softly
color classes and put one color class on
this vertex one on this vertex in one of
these vertex each one of them is a unit
vector if this is the origin and the
angle between any two of them is 120
degrees so the inner product between
these two vectors is minus 1/2 so really
what happens within each color class you
don't have any edges so all edges go
between a different color classes so if
you have an edge the inner product
between the corresponding vectors if you
have an edge is minus 1/2 or let's allow
it to be even a the angle to be larger
so even more negative than minus 1/2
where is if you don't have an edge so
the tail of vertices are either in the
same color that's all in different color
classes so the inner product is minus
1/2 all more positive so I'm allowing
some slackness here so really you could
demand a bit more but I'm not requiring
it so every 3 colorable graph is vector
3 colorable by what I've seen shown here
and it turns out that SDP finds a vector
of 3 coloring in polynomial time so what
so a vector of the coloring is something
that satisfies these equations it's not
a free coloring because it doesn't have
to lie in the plane it might lie in
higher dimensions these vectors might be
in higher dimensions and what Karl
Malone incident showed that if you have
a vector3 coloring then you can round it
to get a coloring that uses D to the
one-third colors
so you can ask whether you can around it
to use fewer colors and there are
examples showing that this is not the
case so these examples are anti
geometric graphs so they are constructed
as follows you placed n vertices on a
sphere or I'll say the dimension of the
scale I'll call it dim I think of this
dimension is roughly log n edges
connected Oh even smaller I just connect
vertices that far apart
that'll follow pout so if you look at
the center of this sphere they make an
angle of at least 120 degrees similar to
what we had here that the angle had to
be loud if there was an edge so the same
thing happens here if the angle is loud
you put an edge so these gloves by
definition our vector 3 colorable
because with each vertex we already have
associated the unit vector and if
there's an edge Bengal is loud
[Music]
and that and the chromatic number the
number of colors you need in order to
really color them legally color of them
is indeed D to the one-third if you set
the dimension correctly so this shows
that the rounding of Calumet Ron in
Sudan is optimum
so often a approximation algorithms for
3-coloring
Express not as a function of vertically
as I did here but as a function of the
number of illnesses and here let me just
go over a sequence of results so the
first approximation algorithm by victors
on a was n to the point five square root
n meaning that if you have a 3 colorable
graph his algorithm could color it with
square root and kyle's
afterwards there was a sequence of Patos
by blood whenever I give him ok
usually when I give two dates for a
paper one is the conference version that
those who know Belgium just so that you
see the timeline so plumbing a sequence
of Patos improved it to 0.375 then cargo
motwani in Sudan in the algorithm that I
showed they achieved D to the 1/3 which
translates if you tell it together with
big docents technique to end to the 1/4
then blamming car girl tailed the semi
definite programming with the techniques
of blunt to get this improved result
then the semi definite programming was
strengthened with triangle constraints
to get a small improvement then people
looked at how is as well and got an even
additional improvement and as far as I
know the current bound is slightly be
noble 0.2 with complicated work leading
up to it but the D would to the 1/3 was
not improved
so from my point of view I find it more
interesting to try to break the D to the
1/3 then to keep on improving the
dependence on n because it somehow
appears that things are getting more and
more complicated and I would like them
to get simpler innocent
so and so the question is how can we
attack this problem of improving but
random instances because a lower bound
okay so let's let's go to now to random
instances
before that let me talk about what I
described before I call it mean free
coloring let's talk from one slide on
max free coloring before going to random
instances
so what's max Li coloring so again
you're given a three color below graph
on n vertices and now the number of
colors that you are allowed to use is
only three and you want to color as many
vertices as possible without violating
any edge and some vertices you are
allowed to are allowed to remain
uncolored so we want to take find let's
say the largest induced sub graph that
you can legally free color so this is a
different notion of approximation for
three coloring so this is very strongly
related to mean free coloring because if
you have a mean free coloring that uses
K colors then you take the three largest
color classes and you have it free of LK
approximation to max blue coloring and
the connection also goes in the other
direction if you have the raw
approximation algorithm for max Lee
coloring you can use it iteratively to
get an algorithm for mean free coloring
because you cut out a row function of
the vertices remove them now use three
fresh colors again color a whole
fraction of what remains and so on so
you suffer an extra lot lots of a factor
of log n in the approximation and in
some cases depending on the form of this
law you don't even lose this extra log N
so all known I I think all known means
recoloring algorithms all the good ones
are the light from max the coloring
algorithms you always thought the
rounding techniques for the semi
definite programming do is let's say
essentially find one independent set but
you can think of it as finding three
independent sets so that's the max blue
coloring and then the cursing
[Music]
so and now not that I wanted to make is
when we look at random instances this
correspondence might break down so it
could be that you have a good max
3-coloring algorithm that you have
managed to Kyle
almost all the graph let's say with leaf
colors it does not necessarily imply
that you'd be able to curl all the graph
with a few colors because the sub graph
that remains might not be from the same
distribution from bleaching of original
graph was and so the government is might
break down
so this is just a point to keep in mind
that for random instances there is this
distinction between these two problems
so let's start with a few results about
a random instances so there is the
random planted model which was
introduced by could say Allah in 1977 so
you think of the graph as being
generated okay there are several ways of
presenting how it is generated at
present one way which I refer to it as
the hosted plain walk so you start with
a host of H sampled at random from GNP
each edge is the present with
probability P so this is not 3 colorable
and then in it you plan to a random 3
coloring which means you partition the
vertex set into three sets and within
each set you remove all the edges so the
graph becomes 3 colorable
and okay they expected degree before
planted planting let's denote it by D
okay
just as it an example of the model so
you have a random host graph so this is
not very hard on but who knows full atom
generator okay you planted it a in it a
free coloring group now you see there
are certain monochromatic edges so this
is illegal
so you remove them from the graph you
remove the colors so that and this is
the graph that you see as input and now
you need to three color it
so the algorithmic task you get this
graph is an input you never see the
original graph H that you started with
oh of course not the planted coloring
and you need to find illegally coloring
not necessarily very planted one so any
legal coloring is fine
so we turns out that it's sufficiently
high densities again there's the
phenomena that I described also in
bisection a random 3 colorable graph is
distributed like a random graph with a
planted random flickering so if you take
you want to sample a random 3 colorable
dense 1 2 3 color but we love this
procedure gives you a sample form
essentially the right distribution and
also it turns out that these graphs can
be colored using spectral algorithms
this was done by a long in Kahala and
also semi-definite programs which are
stronger would also fully color such
graphs if the degree is large enough and
in fact the algorithms can be made to
work even at much lower degrees and may
the distribution of the planted model is
already different from the distribution
of random 3 colorable graphs the
algorithm still continued to work so
pretty well so in any case it seems that
random instances do not capture the
difficulties of worst case instances in
the case of pre color and so we want
what can we do now we can try to look at
the other distribution of random
instances that may be better capture the
difficulties so a natural place to look
is this geometric or anti geometric
graphs that we looked before that get
integrality gap for the semi definite
program for vector coloring so the host
graph if we look at the framework that
we had before is the high dimension a
tight anti geometric graph as I
described before you scatter n vertices
at random on a D dimensional sphere and
we you place
edges between vertices that are far
apart and then in this you plant a
random color link so you partition the
set of vertices at random into three
parts not respecting the geometry of the
air of this picture so every vertex
independently receives one of the three
colors and edges which are monochromatic
are removed so this is the new
distribution of a random instances
you can ask yourself now is it difficult
to find a coloring in this distribution
of how well can you approximately
coloring here so the challenge is as
follow the input graph is generated as I
described here as input you don't get
the geometric representation because if
you got it then you'd know by the fact
that an edge between two distant
vertices it is missing you know that
they are probably that they have to be
of the same color so you get it as an
adjacency matrix without the geometry
and oh a different version of the same
question is already in the model you
don't place between every pair of
vertices which are far apart you place
an edge but only between some of them
that's so in this case just by if you
had this geometric embedding it would
not tell you which vertices need to have
the same color so what do we know about
it so we know that when the dimension is
small up to something like close to 5
log n of this sphere we can find in
polynomial time
in fact the plentiful coloring and this
number is not just an arbitrary number
it has some geometric significance that
they will not describe so at this point
the degree of the graph is roughly n to
the 1 n to the point 3 and we are not we
are not sure what happens so an open
question is to design an algorithm that
colors these graphs in all dimensions
regardless of the dimension of the
sphere yeah so ok so this is exactly the
difficulty here the SDP
even without the planting thinks that
the graph is a three coloring so like
it's not going to point you towards the
coloring it might help you find them
reading and this might help you find the
coloring
but also to prove that it helps you find
the embedding that's not so obvious I
don't know I mean the embedding that you
started with it might give you a
different than baby so there are certain
candidates it's not that we don't have
ideas what to do in this setting it's
just that we don't know how to analyze
what happens and let me describe one
idea that we were trying to follow
so this is the victor 3-coloring
semi-definite program comes in different
versions so I consider this version
where when you had an edge the angle had
to be a hundred and twenty degrees or
larger now in this picture when you have
an edge the angle is exactly hundred and
twenty degrees so you can write a
stronger vector free coloring relaxation
saying that if you have an edge that
angle is exactly 120 degrees now the
question is whether these anti geometric
graphs so
whether these gloves so these graphs
have an embedding the way they were
defined well when you have an edge the
angle is at least 120 degrees but it
might be larger so they also have an
embedding in which when there's an edge
the angle is exactly hundred and twenty
degrees if not then they sdp would
recognize let's say that before the
planting they are not 3 colorable so
after the planting probably the solution
that it gives is correlated with the
3-coloring
so the that's the hope here and this
might be a way to improve over B to the
1/3 approximation ratio because it
handles the most difficult class of
instances for the previous bounds so I
think that so this is a nice geometric
question if you can treat it like a skit
even independently of its application in
coloring whether when you have an
embedding of points on the sphere you
can forever embed them in a different
sphere maybe in higher dimension
satisfying some other properties at best
this approach would lead to some
approximation I show which is it would
still be due to some power smaller than
1/3 maybe 1/10 I don't know what the
explicit sit constant will be here
I didn't compute it you can compute an
explicit constant and these fellows form
walk of Moses so that even the strongest
DP has an integral attica but not D to
the one-third something
so any questions about coloring for
certain so like it's a sequence of
algorithms you start like with the like
some of the algorithms that work for
random graphs for random instances prior
to the semi definite and spectral
techniques like counting common
neighbors and things like that they work
at very when the sphere is a very low
dimension as you increase that they
mention it becomes more complicated but
their combinatorial they don't go
through that we had so this is a partial
answer to
chantal's question some of the
algorithms look like you take a sample
try to color it and extend the coloring
and so on so yeah these are the kind of
algorithms that work but as the
dimension gets larger the graph becomes
in a sense more sparse the degree goes
down and they stop walking so
[Music]
is if the colored 3-coloring is sort of
strongly unique or unique or something
then coloring a sample might tell you
the whole story that's true
in low dimensions so in low dimensions
you can prove two things you can prove
that the coloring is unique in higher
dimensions we don't know and the other
you can prove with the dimension is low
enough that if you color a small sample
you can extend it to the coloring of the
Holga
but for this the dimension has to be
small
okay so now I'll move to a different
problem unique games so I'll describe it
as a coloring problem so we have a graph
we have K colors on every edge of the
graph you have some permutation that is
specific for that particular edge and
given as part of the input and the goal
is to color the vertices of the graph
using these K colors and you want to
maximize the number of legally colored
edges well in edges legally colored if
the color of one endpoint when you apply
the permutation of the edge to it you
get the color of the other endpoint
that's unique games and I suppose most
people in the audience health of the
unique games conjecture that says that
for every epsilon think of epsilon and
Delta is being small close to zero you
can choose sufficiently large K such as
it is NP how to distinguish between
instances in which you can legally
colored almost all the edges and
instances in which any coloring legally
colors only a very small fraction of the
edges that it's NP how to distinguish
between these instances let's say a few
words about random instances so first
maybe I should say those extensive you
research on the unique games conjecture
and its implications and I don't have
time to mention it even smells so much
and so a lot of instances of unique
games are approximately much better than
what the unique games conjecture say and
in fact we have much stronger statements
so these are taken from these two walks
there so the beginning may be was this
walk of Al all right I'll that you can
think of it as unique games on when it
is expanded because I'd got in a special
case two random crafts and this really
to of this point home by looking at
several models so let me describe these
results so he'll fall semi random models
for unique and so not just random
they're semi random in the sense that
that there's also an adversary that
to the some parts of the god of the
input instance we can think of an
instance as generated in four steps so
if you want to generate an instance a
yes instance of the unique gain in which
almost all edges are colored legally we
can generate it as follow we first pick
the graph the constraint graph then we
pick the permutations along with the
edges and we pick them in such a way
that the instance is completely
satisfiable so the way of doing it you
can think of a coloring of the graph and
then pick permutations that are
consistent with this coloring there
after you pick at random a small set of
edges that you want to co-opt and then
or not at random out of it early and
then on these edges that you want to
collapse you choose some other
publications that would not fit so that
these edges would not be satisfied so
that's a general recipe of choosing how
you either you can choose over an
adversary can choose an instance which
is 1 minus epsilon satisfiable and the
theorem says it sounds a very strong
like so if epsilon is small think of it
very close to 0 and at least one of the
above 4 selections was made at random
you have here four choices so you can
allow an adversary to choose any three
of them to whatever he wants in any
three but one of them has to be random
then does the randomized for the normal
time coloring algorithm for which most
edges are legally colored so that's an
approximation I show much better than
what the unique games conjecture says
that it's how to do
so in fact it's not just really one
algorithm it's you need to somehow
tailor the algorithm to which step is
random but in general you can think of
it as one output you can try or buy all
four algorithms and one of them would
walk okay so as many results on random
instances also hear there's some
condition on the average degree of the
graph like the graph has to be of large
enough degree for the algorithm to walk
so so it looks like unique games at
least if we look at evidence for more
random instances doesn't seem to be a
difficult problem so any questions about
yeah I thought you would say by semi
random I can delete some of the edges
there are many different semi random
models so that's one of them we might
hear on maybe you know I take the random
graph but I'm going to delete some edges
so it still remains the random graph so
what if you delete them at random okay I
mean you you can start playing with the
model more and try to see how far you go
but just let's say deleting edges you
can probably incorporate it is just a
new graph so I'm not sure if you to be 5
out 4 out of 5 in this case
I my first intuition would be that it
would not change the picture by much
well I can skew the degree distribution
all kinds of things right yeah but even
as we said in some of these models the
graph is not random and you can still do
it so you don't need the graph to be
random it's enough that some other
aspect is random for these algorithms so
that's the point is that even if the
guff is not random you can do it okay so
the last problem I want to look at this
dense case up graph so here the input is
the graph on n vertices and a fellow
metal okay and the goal is to find the
subgraph induce some K vertices of
highest average degree that induces the
largest amount number of edges so this
problem is np-hard it generalizes K
clique as a special case the best
approximation ratio is known of the form
n to some power Delta roughly 1/4 and as
far as we know maybe you can okay maybe
you can approximate it within a ratio of
2 in quasi-polynomial time the
polynomial time if you could do it in
polynomial time then and if you would
have sub exponential time algorithms but
maybe in quasi-polynomial time you can
do it so it's a game wide open this
problem so here's a random model for the
dense case up of problem so you have
some host graph G allowed graph and this
is a random graph with 8h probability P
and in it you take a set of vertices and
plant a instead of the original graph a
graph H of higher education city Q so if
this Q is sufficiently large op and P
this is going to be the densest sub
graph in your graph so this is a random
or then
so the question is can you let's say
detect h in such a hunter model and
he'll okay
that's a reminder of the model so here's
something that you can do so think for
example that the average degree in h is
larger than the number of vertices in h
to the power of 1/3 well as the average
degree mg is smaller than n to the one
third okay what would happen in that
case
so it's not how to see by let's say a
Union bound that G would not have any
cliques of size 4 you just do the the
expected number of cliques of size 4 is
going to be smaller than 1 and it's
known also that H gloves whose average
degree is smaller than the number of
vertices to the one third will have
cliques of size 4 so there are something
yeah I mean they're very constant yeah I
mean so yeah yeah let's think one fill
plus epsilon and here maybe one-third
minus X you know think of it okay so in
this case we will detect the fact that
we planted H inside G and this is a
starting point of an algorithm so in
general we can detect the existence of H
that H was planted in G whenever the log
density like the power when we look at
the average degree in H so that's a put
the green we take log to the base of K
if this is larger then log to the base
of end of the average degree in G
because whenever it's larger there is a
certain small induce sub graph that
would appeal in H but will not appear in
G by the same kind of argument by Union
bound so we can look for this subclass
and if they exist we know that some H
was planted so for example for K for the
log density the critical log density is
one-third
for log density above 130 a fall appears
below one third it doesn't appeal so
this was they used a as a starting point
or the key insight that led to improve
the current best approximation ratio for
dense case above in the worst case
instances and to the one fall
so this log density reports that you get
it from these random instances they
inspired and was the basis for the I
guess currently best approximation I've
got it in for dense case up top and
here's an open question on this so
suppose that G now the a the large graph
its average the day is slightly below
square root of n you plant in it a sub
graph of size square root of n and it's
average degree is slightly below but
more so then into the 1/4 so the log
density of this is slightly smaller than
the log density of this car now if you
look at this particular instance if you
look for dense case sub cover we were
looking for a sub graph of size K so H
has average degree roughly n to the 1/4
slightly below and slowly that's take
you know I should have been K to the K
today
that's an K to the point 4 8 which is
more like n to the 1/4 that's a typo
here so the degree here is like n to the
1/4 not K to the 1/4 so H has degree
roughly n to the 1/4 well as g then if
you just take it then a sub off within g
of size square root n it would be rough
it was at best you'd be able to pick
something like a tree or something that
logically would be constant maybe
logarithmic not more so this is an
instance where like to get an
approximation i show better than n to
the 1/4
you bet or close to
to the 1/4 you better detect H and the
open question is can you detect the
existence of H and here I arranged it in
such a way that the log density of H is
smaller than the log density of G so in
terms of small sub graphs H does not
have small sub costs that G does not
have so the question is can you detect
age and this currently is the obstacle
to improving over the N to the 1/4
approximation ratio for dense K sub
graph and let me make a bold conjecture
ok that if you improve just this random
instance you'd be also able to improve
the worse case in sense that this random
instance really captures the
difficulties in the worst case and the
reason I'm making this conjecture is
this is what happened
in the previous algorithm like once we
were able to deal with this planted
instances everything with extra work
worked also for worst case instances ok
so let me summarize so we've seen five
problems so for max 3sat random
instances appear to be as hard as wall
space instances for mean bisection
random instances are easy or mean free
coloring also random instances are easy
but there is an interesting distribution
that is worth studying that of this
random anti geometric graphs and it
could be that by studying it you'd also
be able to learn something about wall
space instances so unique and semi
random of what maybe I should call them
quota random instances because adversary
fixes three paths and they're random
aspect is just one part so even these
instances are easy so it's not clear how
what the difficult instances should look
like
and for dense case subgraph I would say
this is like a success story in the
census this is a case we are really by
started looking at random instances we
got involvement in worst case instances
so this is like a template I would like
to follow also not clear I mean the
paper is not easy I mean there are many
steps to do beyond this yeah
I didn't think of that other than so
much so I don't have anything to say
yeah
otherwise let's think the speaker again
and we'll hop
[Applause]
[Music]